haha the gyro can experience I will not
knock anybody that is dealing with any
type of mental struggle because that is
something that's so serious because
nobody understands right what that is
except that person right so I never I
never talk as if that's an easy thing I
talk as if that's a thing that I don't
fully know about so you can only you can
only have some type of remorse in
feeling of understanding for people that
are battling any type of mental illness
or mental health because that's just a
different it's a different monster and
different machines so whatever the
reasons to escape that are for you and
from you you know that's that's
something that's TBD to be determined
between you and whoever's trying to help
you people on the outside
we got no right we got no right if
you're not [ __ ] dealing with the same
thing you got no right to judge that
ever there's no way we can understand
what's going I'm no I can understand
what's going on your head other than you
telling me about and me trying to
decipher it and trying to put it into
words but that's one of the more
interesting things about talking to
people it's like when you when you talk
to people and you find out how they feel
and think about things it shifts your
own ideas of what life is and and and
I'm try to look at life through other
people's eyes and the only way you get
that is through them talking
I mean I'm dealing with it now with my
kids you know I got two teenagers so my
daughter you know my daughter got mad
this is a while ago she got so mad she
just forget it was like it was like a
little rage I didn't attack her for it
I said there's something that made you
do that it's bigger than just this it's
not about what we're dealing with now I
said that was double something else that
I've never seen and I said I'm gonna
give you a second take some time to
yourself I said later if you want to
talk about anything your dad is here so
let's let's talk if you want to and we
got this thing called free speaking zone
and our house free speaking zone means
as a parent I can't get mad at you about
what you said I got to give you a
conversation based off of what you said
and I gotta act as if you're not Mike
ciao for that moment you cannot abuse
free speaking zone though you can't
abuse it that don't mean every time
you're in trouble free speaking zone
you're abusing and now you risk free
speaking zone going away I like that
idea so you gotta use it correctly so
you know my daughter came to me and and
in like the nicest voice she was like
free speaking zone and I was like yeah I
said what's up and she just started
talking to me about some things that
were bothering her and when when we
talked what I found is I can relate to
my daughter because I know for sure that
where I come from it's allowed me to see
exactly what she's seeing plus so much
more put so much more and this was a
this was a time where the hair was an
issue my daughter went through a big
hair thing you know she wanted her hair
to be a certain way and the hair
wouldn't there was no way to her hair
was going to look like what she wanted
it to mmm so the discussion was honey as
a young black girl your hair is not
gonna do what your friends hair does you
know my daughter goes to a private
school it is white girls here you got
some mixed girls here and you know these
girls are out and they can jump in the
pool get out and their hair is a certain
way I'm like honey yours isn't gonna do
that but if you want a different look
then that means that we can work on ways
to obtain it but honey it's not gonna
happen overnight
and I had to make sure that my daughter
understood how beautiful she was I had
to make sure that my daughter understood
why it's okay for her hair to be
different and be unique and not the same
I had to go into a full father
programming of making you understand
your value and my daughter needed that
but it wasn't it wasn't something that
just came out of nowhere like dad I want
to talk to you about my hair it was an
anger that she later then came and
wanted to discuss but if I didn't have
the free speaking zone
that's the [ __ ] that just would have
been in and never taught it never talked
about yeah but I gave her something that
she used as a as a reason to say what I
don't like and don't judge me dad but
this is really making me mad well it
seems like you've developed this
philosophy that applies not just to work
and not just to success but also to
family and relationships there's a lot
of carryover in all of this
it's like accepting things for what they
are but looking at a positive way to
improve them even in terms of just
communication with your family I mean
that's priority yeah priority number one
I mean that's this it's it's so it's so
dope to be able to build what we're
building because it's not a tradition
this is not we don't have a family
tradition where the first right this is
the first right I don't come from mom
and dad same house kids dogs and dinner
at night at 6:00 p.m. I don't come from
that right I don't know how to do that
so we are now learning that you know
divorced ex-wife new wife step kids new
kid brothers and sisters coincide with
ex-wife new wife make sure that we all
understand this is our world how do we
co-parent bumps of course figuring it
out of course kids household in our
household must build something dinners
let's make this a thing conversations no
phones let's make it a thing movie night
Taco Tuesdays game night all this silly
[ __ ] that you may look past our memories
family trips family walks walking the
dogs together all of this [ __ ] we're
building so I'm fascinated at giving my
kids stories to hold on to when they get
older remember that time when we did
said things
that thing said thing where are we at
that summer remember when such and such
happened and you fell in the thing and
dad had to come get you
oh my god you know what dad you know I
want to go back to you know what we want
to do we're building it so my hope is
that as I grow older I'm able to look at
a new a new era within the heart within
his heart family name this heart
legacy I'm looking at I'm looking at
generations you know I got two sons I
got two sons man that's a that's an
unbelievable thing because this name
goes I got a daughter that's my oldest
I'm about to have another daughter like
now it's like [ __ ] have you really it's
bigger than you it's it's about this and
it's about what they have but it's about
what they remember I'm doing my part in
life to go back to what we talked about
earlier by making this generation better
than what I was I'm giving you the
[ __ ] tools guys you don't got to do
what I do you don't got to be what I am
but I'm giving you the tools to at least
want to aspire to be
[Applause]